what up space fam golden here from anime
uproar back at it again to discuss the
latest and craziest developments in the
one punch man story and what an insane
chapter we got today garo confronts
other dragon level threats we get more
from platinum s which is always exciting
everyone sees king finally make a move
and saitama shows up to confront garrow
i can barely believe all that happened
in just one chapter so definitely make
sure to stay tuned for this one if you
do enjoy these one punch man videos and
want to keep them coming you know what
to do channel the sight them all within
and serious punch that like button
remember that smashing that like button
is sight to my energy and passing is
fear or ugly energy so you know choose
wisely if you haven't make this the
video you subscribe and this is crucial
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one punch man videos and updates
and while you wait for the next exciting
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my one punch man playlist that includes
videos on all the s-class heroes all
dragon and god level monsters and more
link to that is in the description and
now without further ado let's jump into
it spoilers and all the cover of this
chapter is definitely a bit of
foreshadowing hyping up saitama's return
at the end saitama looking very very
cool and unusually serious in this panel
the narrator says that i quote smash
everything until the edge of the world
is it just hype nonsense or is it a
reference to a god character who seems
to live along the edge of this world and
the next either way i'm hyped this
chapter is called ultimate hellfire
burst wave motion cannon i love how long
that name is and it also lets us know
that this will be the chapter where we
see the legendary king respond to
platinum s finally i can't wait to get
to that part king never disappoints for
now we just see king standing above
platinum s people are wondering why he's
still not attacking and i gotta give it
to murata platinum s is drawn insanely
well here he's looking very cool and
it's times like this where regardless of
how awesome the story is itself i just
appreciate seeing this level of drawing
we carry on in the chapter and people
finally react to his transformation
saying he shrank but that he
nevertheless has an overwhelming
presence he still obviously got stronger
and yeah i definitely feel some dragon
ball z influence there because platinum
s is definitely reminding me of boo let
me know if that's just me and in dragon
ball z you regularly see leaner dudes
take out jack fighters so you see that
principle here as well child emperor is
still wondering why exactly king isn't
using his secret technique in classic
one punch man fashion he comes to the
conclusion that it's not because the
technique doesn't exist but rather it's
because king must have been waiting for
the final form before he wipes out
platinum s it must be a tactic for
asserting dominance and spreading panic
between all the monsters and then he
adds hilariously that's the number one
for you this never gets old and it's
even funnier because that would actually
make sense imagine if you let your
opponent reach their final form and then
crush them the weaker monsters would
obviously lose their minds and i
absolutely love how much of an effect
each one of king's movements no matter
how small has on everybody the dude just
uncrosses his arms and everyone goes
insane child emperor is sweating
uncontrollably as he screams king has
uncrossed his arms people think he's
finally preparing to attack while king
himself is wondering if the monsters
will spare his life if he grovels if he
pretty much begs for his life in the
meantime everyone assumes that he'll use
the famous ultimate hellfire burst wave
motion cannon attack all the heroes
cheer him on sure of their victory and
instead of getting pumped up of course
king is just freaking out wondering if
they really want to see him die that
badly platinum s actually slaps around
atomic samurai puri puri prisoner and
the others saying he has no time for
canon father a part of me thought
hopefully this doesn't lead to them
thinking king couldn't help them but
they are all right at the end of the day
so it could be just king tactically from
their perspective not choosing to engage
in platinum s just yet platinum s wants
to give king what he thinks that king
wants which is a face-off against his
perfect 54 trillion combined form
platinum s is confident in himself now
obviously but he still thinks king is
the real deal and asks him to attack
with his ultimate hellfire burst wave
motion cannon attack he promises that as
soon as he does so platinum s will slice
off his head king is contemplating
groveling again nothing new before we
switch to ugly and bang ugly thinks this
is the perfect opportunity bang is beat
up right now after all because of his
fight with garro bomb is trying to get
up and help bang but he's just too beat
up ugly goes in to break bang himself as
he says meanwhile bang is just hoping
that garo will listen to the voice
inside his heart we were mentioning
during the last chapter that clearly
bang was getting togaro somewhat his
mask was crumbling which symbolizes
monsterization and he was holding his
head in his hands clearly troubled even
during the last chapter it wasn't hard
to predict that bang may help garo in
this situation and save him from ugly
and here we get a significant portion of
his armor breaking revealing garo's
human eye beneath to me again this
symbolizes that bang really got through
to him significantly although obviously
we can't imagine garo will completely
change his way so easily but it's still
a start clearly garo's touched enough to
save bang from ugly's body melting
attack and the action here is
extraordinary garo just kicks through
the giant ugly body and then keeps
moving we jump back to king who is
contemplating the fact that there is no
ultimate hellfire burst wave motion
cannon attack but as he's doing so he
actually starts screaming the name of
the attack gotta respect the fact that
he'd take this chance while most likely
he'd just look like a dude screaming
without anything happening however as we
know king's superpower is being super
lucky and as he shouts the title of his
attack we see garrow making his way into
the battlefield garrow hits platinum s
evil natural water attacks him and he
attacks back sending the water in every
direction and garo did all this
extremely quickly so that as we could
all guess it looked to everyone else
like king's attack just did all this
insane damage we even see metal bats
smiling from a distance saying king
pulled it off king is more shocked than
anyone at what happened his expression
is absolutely hilarious as always we
jump to ugly who starts melting like a
wicked witch and we see garo finally
land a good distance from king and where
all the damage took place he even utters
the words old man showing he's thinking
about bang and his humanity is coming
through here you even see a tear coming
down bang's eye i didn't think i'd be so
moved by their sensei student
relationship but yeah i was wrong and
then as if that already wasn't enough
for one chapter as if that wasn't
already a great chapter it ends with
saitama coming back blast has warped
them here right in front of garrow i've
been waiting for this for so long and
it's finally here saitama flashy flash
and the monster and that is the end of
this epic chapter it's also funny how
the entrance contrasts with the epic
cover page where saitama looked like he
landed in such an epic heroic fashion
here they just clumsily fell on the
ground with no idea what's going on
looking confused garo and saitama are
together and now we get to look forward
to their reactions to meeting up again
and their eventual fight as well wow
amazing stuff and i'm loving how
consistent murata has been with one
punch chapters as of late amazing
consistency and quality as always let me
know in the comments how you felt about
this chapter what do you expect to see
happening in the next one and who was
your mvp this time around i gotta go
with king yeah gar was amazing too but
king's just so funny and i love the fact
that he actually blurted out the attack
name without knowing what would happen
i'm glad he hasn't adjusted to how lucky
he is and always sweats it out even
though things always turn out fine if
you did enjoy this review and you want
to keep them coming you know what to do
channel decide them within and serious
punch that like button remember that
smashing that like button is saitama
energy and passing is fear or ugly
energy so choose wisely if you haven't
make this the video you subscribe and
hit that notification bell to turn on
all notifications or you will miss
future one punch man videos and updates
and while you wait for the next exciting
chapter to drop feel free to check out
my one punch man playlist that includes
videos on all s-class heroes all dragon
and god level monsters and more link to
that is in the description and i
especially want to thank the patron
squad over on patreon and here on
youtube who helped make videos like this
one possible first and foremost i want
to thank the patron of legend the one
acknowledged by lord wigo himself alpha
sigma and other one tier patrons the
ones who stay on top all clans ingrata
al jatal pate hepa the red haired fox
hinokami and water the toasted chi cory
mcgowan the spike lonely dakar dylan
isadore spidey life tinel tungsten
tarkis big buddhist jeremy cummings and
che a whitley and our pro hero tier
patrons the one and only gilgamesh
steelers angel cruz very gucci alicia
actor bonnie parks joanne garcia fat boy
games kylo might be a duck jessica
rabbit jeremy phillips ali baitnia and
temple thank you all so much if you do
enjoy our work you can support more of
it by going over to patreon.com anime
upload and becoming a patron today for
as little as one dollar if you do so you
get a name feature in future videos
alongside these amazing people right
here and you'll even get access to our
private patron only discord where we
talk about anime life and of course
thank meme so check out patreon.com
anime upload link in the description if
you're interested you can also join the
youtube channel by clicking that blue
join button next to the subscribe button
that you've hopefully already destroyed
so yeah you can support more content
that way if you prefer whichever way you
support us you can get the same great
benefits thanks again and until next
time see ya space cowboys
[Music]
you